[Music]
good afternoon everybody welcome to the
star con security keys and anti-phishing
my name is Sriram Cara I'm a product
manager and enterprise authentication
and security and I have my colleague
here a Christian man who is also
including flowers so today we're gonna
be talking about authentication and
security keys in particular so here is
the agenda in front of us we'll start
with a brief refresher on why passwords
you know basically suck or what are the
MFA options we have at Google with a
specific focus in security keys and
we're gonna be doing a deep dive into a
product announcement we made earlier
today an exciting new feature where you
can use your phone as a u2f security key
and then if all goes to plan it will
have some time left for Q&A so talking
of Q&A we'd like you to try out this new
feature called a Dodi Q&A which you can
access through the cloud next app if you
can find our session you will find a
link below the session description to
Dori Q&A that the thing about Dori is
you can ask questions anytime in the app
and then you can also see what questions
others are asking and you can vote on
them and so if there are a lot of
questions we will start with the ones
that are most popular and work our way
down words we also have two mics we will
come to them if that's your preferred
way to ask questions you can always do
that now with that let's get started
with with passwords so so what's wrong
with passwords for starters weak
passwords are everywhere but in 2015 a
study based on the Verizon data breach
analysis showed that these are the two
most popular passwords that were found
in that in that breach the thing is
three years later in 2018 when the same
analysis was done based on more updated
data breaches the situation is still the
same right I don't know how many of you
notice it but the slide that the date in
the slide changed in 2015 to 2018 now
the way organizations typically deal
with these weak passwords is by
enforcing complexity rules on
composition rules essentially all of us
have seen them password should require
Piquet is when little kids when one
number and so on and so forth the
problem with these composition rules
firstly is that it's a pain for users
users are super frustrated if you don't
trust me just look at how frustrated
that user looks right the other part
about these complexity rules they don't
even work right research has shown that
when you have hardwired composition
rules like this users deal with them in
extremely predictable ways like the
replays a with the act symbol the adders
exclamation mark at the end of the word
and so on so there are very predictable
ways in which users deal with these
composition rules and so they don't
really add anything any anything
significant in terms of security but it
just adds frustration from users so
right now the the sort of the security
best practice is is to take away the
burden from the users and an offload the
burden onto the on to the services so
that service providers like Google and
others can enforce what is wrong
passwords based on current understanding
of security best practices comparing
passwords with password breach databases
and so on and so forth now even if you
have overcome the weak password problem
using security base practices a strong
password is no good if it is stolen and
passwords are stolen all the time so
based on our research here are the top
three ways in which password is stolen
no surprise there data breaches of
third-party services malware that log
you passwords as they're being typed and
next we'll trade them and the big one
phishing the reason I said phishing is
the big one compared to the other ones
is also going back to is based on some
research we did a few years ago when we
keep updating that research is we looked
at a user who was prone to a phishing
attack and let's say the credential was
compromised in a phishing attack and we
compared the likelihood of such users
getting compromised completely that is
the occur losing access to their account
as compared to a randomly selected gmail
account so that hijacking likelihood of
a fish-eat-fish user was 500 times a
normal user or randomly selected user
this is likelihood is significantly
lower for other forms of credential
compromised
in particular you can see even if your
password wasn't was found in a breach
it's only ten times worse whereas if you
were fished it is five hundred times
worse the reasons for this difference is
also is interesting this is just one
example why one reason why this
significant difference between there it
is because we as a service provider we
can provide certain protections against
leaked passwords that don't apply in the
phishing case like this is a part of
that same program we did a few years ago
we found compromised credentials from
various breaches we found a certain
number of them were were actually valid
passwords for for the gmail accounts and
we will be were immediately able to lock
those accounts down now this kind of a
thing it is a batch process it's not
possible in a phishing attack where by
the time we come to know of it it's it's
it's probably too late
phishing is also becoming more potent
relative to malware right it is becoming
more impossible because if automated
phishing kits that are available that
even fish multifactor as we will see in
a moment and malware is becoming harder
to write and fishing is just brutally
effective so phishing is just there are
just more phishing sites and more
fishing kits available now as compared
to modern so it's not all bad news
though the good news here is at Google
then even if a malicious actor has a
username and password in 99.9% of the
cases Google is able to do some risk
analysis you know based on a
geographical location device security
history and so on and block 99% of those
malicious accesses but the 0.1% are also
important so the answer for those 0.1%
typically has been multi-factor
authentication now multi-factor
authentication methods many of them are
available SMS totp mobile push and so on
and so forth but many of them have their
own problems usability is one of them
fish ability is is the bigger of the two
fish because in some sense an OTP is
also something that the user knows
it's not a long lived knowledge but it's
a short lived knowledge that you just
learned like maybe a minute ago and it
can be fished in exactly the same way
that the primary factor can be fished
so the otps and most the traditional MFA
methods are not really the solution to
all of the problems so they were right
way to think about MFA is that it is a
it provides a spectrum of assurance MFA
methods are not all the same so here's
what we would recommend right any MFA is
better than no MFA that's that's number
one the second part of it is of all the
available methods if you put them on a
scale SMS and voice based codes are the
least secure of these methods because
not only are they fishable but they also
have other problems that are now
well-known which include know as a seven
vulnerabilities carrier social
engineering attacks and so on so so it's
widely now known that SMS is is the
weakest of all of the large but it's
still better than nothing
the second bob a bucket of MFA methods
we have all the other codes we have
backup codes authentic Google
Authenticator or totp based apps and
then mobile push methods such as Google
prompt these don't have this all of the
problems of SMS but still all these
three can be fished and increasingly
we're finding phishing attacks
there are fishing kits that make it very
easy for for these to be fished in real
time so the onset of this phishing
problem essentially is is Hardware fight
of security keys and these are the only
MFA method that have been designed to be
resistant to phishing you know from the
ground up so to talk more about Fido
I'm gonna call Christian to come up hi
folks I am Christian and I'm a product
manager at Google working on strong
authentication and security keys so I
want to tell you a little bit more about
you know what we do at Google to prevent
phishing or at least try and Corbett
we've had these security keys you know
in use on Google accounts for the better
part of like three four years we've even
made the statement last year
I believe it was during next where we
said that you know no Google account has
successfully been fished or at least
Googler Google stuff has essentially
been fished since we've deployed the the
security key technology which is really
the primary purpose of this the the core
issue really that users are struggling
with nowadays when authenticating is
that they arrive at a website and enter
their credentials but have no way of
knowing that that website is really the
correct legitimate website that they're
interacting with yes there is TLS
certificates that you can go and
validate there are like telltale signs
hopefully in the URL address bar but
these things are tricky and if you go by
the security zone Donald Lee on the show
floor we have two laptops set up next to
each other one is an official website
and the other one it's not and it's very
very hard to tell right it just is most
of us here at the conference are
security professionals and even for us
it is tricky especially if you know
that's not the only thing that we want
to do on that webpage it's not all about
validating URLs for us we actually want
to get the job done right you want to
send an email we want to log in we're
gonna get access to file so we're not
spending that much time checking URLs
every day and that really is kind of the
primary problem here in securing keys
are meant to address that we
specifically developed the security key
technology together with industry to
solve and address that problem and the
way that that works is there we go
the way that that works is we the
security key basically communicates
locally to the hosts and in other words
you plug it in there is information
being sent from the host to the security
key it does validation also based on the
origin like where you are you're
browsing to you and then will not
release the signature so you say until
it recognizes that it's on the correct
website that it wants to interact with
and and we look at that and a little bit
more detail here in a couple of slides
so very very simple if you're on the
correct URL the security key works if
not it doesn't like pretty
straightforward um
squares open standard as I said earlier
we work in two standards barri since
these standards organizations the one is
in the w3c World Wide Web Consortium and
recently we reach w3c recommendation
status that means usually that web
browser is kind of look at what the w3c
is coming up with typically also are
involved in the standardization process
and they usually pick up standards that
reach recommended state as a
recommendation in the w3c and that is
why we've seen folks like edge Mozilla
Firefox
of course Chrome as well as Safari in
tech preview actually you know take this
seriously and start doing implementation
we've recently moved over I guess about
three four weeks ago in anticipation of
the launch today which which I'll show a
demo about we've moved over to the w3c
standard as opposed to what we were
doing before which was kind of like a
pre you know fully w3c rectified
standard called u2f which is basically
the protocol between a web server and
your log in device right so if your
website then you want to implement this
cool new stuff here you need to
understand the w3c web event protocol
there is another protocol involved here
which is called C tab the client to
authenticate a protocol that is still
being standardized in fighter but a lot
less I guess folks in the world really
need to know about that protocol that's
the one that your device your browser
your platform needs to communicate to
the security key one way to communicate
this using USB there's a standardized
framing in a format for doing this
communication if you are interested in
developing security keys then of course
you need to understand that protocol but
if you're a web developer you want to
implement this in your website you
absolutely don't you only need to
understand whittles then if you want to
make security keys of course it's an
open standard anyone can participate
anyone can make a security key and
Google will you know as folks know will
pretty much accept any security key from
any vendor as long with you adhere to
the standards that key will work on on
Google properties so we'll talk a little
bit more about that particular protocol
here in a second but the the important
thing here is like this is mediated by
Chrome or by your browser or your
platform on your machine this
communication and then it goes over
either USB NFC Near Field Communication
or Bluetooth Low Energy
those are the three standardized
transports on that level so that's kind
of like if you're interested like how
Fido and w3c kind of both fit into this
process a little bit in their last year
at next we introduced the patent
security key it has one more option
right there is security keys out there
from many vendors anyone can make
security keys that you know
behaves according to the standard and
works with with property supporting
we're both in or security keys but we
wanted to introduce one more option one
option that basically has a little bit
of Google goodness in there and that's
what we did in the Titan security key
essentially as we said you know it's a
phishing resistant second factor we've
said that a bunch of times but more
importantly it includes a secure element
with firmware that was written by Google
which you can then use and and gives you
this that little bit of governor extra
goodness in there it's an open ecosystem
the key will work with any other website
that understands wibbels then and
there's many of these different websites
out there today
yours is a more detailed slide on how
the security key actually works when
you're trying to log in so go through
this and if there's questions at the
ends we can we can delve in a little bit
deeper but I do think it's important to
at least understand this ad the kind of
like superficial level so this gets one
level below kind of just understanding
that there's comms happening between
these devices so how this works is when
I try to log into www.google.com and at
work West is a server and the very next
thing the server will do once I've
entered my username and my password the
server will generate a cryptographic
challenge now in this example we assume
that the user have already registered
their security key with their Google
account at some point in time before
this happens right registration is very
simple the key generates a unique public
private key keeper it gives a public key
to the service Google in this case and
Google will store that against this
particular account so Alice in this
example is trying to sign in and Google
knows that there is a particular public
key that belongs to Alice on file at the
server at Google and we send a
cryptographic challenge basically for
freshness right we say here are some
random data you're going to need to do
something with that we just passed that
along so the random data is passed along
to the client in this case of the phone
the very next thing that happens is
chrome looks at or the browser looks at
the url bar all the web origin and sees
ah this is for google.com okay that's
cool so we're gonna remember that and
then we're gonna send that information
on over the sheet that protocol remember
everything happening on the left side of
the picture is I would
the receivables then on the right side
of the picture that communication is
happening by a C tab so we're gonna send
this information from the browser to the
security key over USB in this case and
we're gonna include the challenge that
the server sends but we're also gonna
include kind of like a caller ID like
who has the actual property asking for
this signature look at the URL bar will
strip that out and we'll send that along
over the USB protocol to the security
security key will then generate a
cryptographic signature so basically it
takes the challenge it signs it using
the private key that it generated over a
year ago or whenever when you register
the key it generates this signature and
it sends the signature all the way back
via the USB protocol and via web oh then
all the way back to the server the
server looks at this sees that the
challenge that it sent is correct it
assigned by the private key that the
security key knows the server doesn't
know the private key though the server
only knows the public key but using
public private cryptography or public
private key cryptography it can verify
that the key knows the correct secret
without ever exposing that secret to the
server itself how great is that for data
breaches right if something happens to
the server nowadays passwords are
exposed you know we can run through
doesn't matter if the positive is hashed
or whatever like rainbow tables and
other stuff out there passwords gets
cracked because of the fact that we use
symmetric authentication on the web
today
your positive can be cracked in this
example even if someone if there's a
data breach over at the server side and
things get compromised yes they'll have
your username to have your password but
they will never have your private key
because that private key is never stored
in the server the public key is stored
in the server that allows the server to
know that you have the right security
key but it never allows the server to
impersonate that said security key which
is really cool really nifty the other
thing of course here is that we saw and
we don't only sign the challenge we also
sign the web origin so the server is
absolutely certain that you are looking
at the correct website at the point in
time when the security key was presented
so both of these two things are signed
together both the challenge and the web
origin and that all gets sent you know
down to you to the server the user is
looking at the incorrect website the
incorrect thing will be signed and the
server will simply reject it so pretty
straightforward
um and we'll kind of look at something
else you're in more detail in a second
so what we're really here to talk about
and at this point it's kind of old news
right we've set it from this morning or
is its keynote and then we Revere it in
the security spotlight session we wanted
to make things a little easier for users
it's great to have multiple options in
security keys NFC USB maybe a Bluetooth
key that I can use but you know it's
still an additional device that I have
to carry around how cool would it be if
the thing that's already in my pocket my
mobile phone could just be my security
key for my Google account now we're
gonna say well that's nothing I've been
using my phone to a sandy gage for years
well that's true it started out with
using SMS as an one-time password sent
to a phone then we started looking at
like Authenticator application is it
running on the phone generating one-time
passwords even push authentication
nowadays right you get a message and you
say yes and the technology that you're
going to look at right now is very
similar in the user experience right you
also look at the phone and say yes to a
message the critical difference is that
message is not going via the cloud and
there's some slides in your later where
we kind of break that ole login process
down and where we see the difference
between traditional push based
authentication and this technology here
because there's a local channel a local
proximity channel between the laptop and
my mobile phone we can apply the same
protocol which makes sure the user is
rook we're looking at the right website
at the point in time when they're trying
to sign in that really is kind of the
breakthrough here very very very simple
kind of concept but obviously the
implementation is hard because you have
to deal with Bluetooth and different
browsers there are platforms but in the
end all these things kind of make up a
cohesive whole which gives you a user
experience that users are used to
they've been doing it for years but this
time really giving that that elevated
threat protection of the phishing
protection that that security keys and
the protocol have built in so pretty
straightforward right and then there's
one last thing here which we'll talk
about a little bit later if you happen
to have a pixel three last year when we
announce a pixel 3 we also mentioned
that the pixel 3 has a Titan M sharp in
there so there's a cryptographic secure
element built by Google you know that
does a bunch of things in that blog post
at the time we kind of alluded to the
fact that hey maybe later this thing can
also be used as a security key and I
guess that time is now so on a pixel 3
we're actually using and storing your
phyto key material the
cryptographic material that we use to
generate these signatures directly in
that secure element and the secure
element actually happens to be hardwired
to the volume down button on my pixel
phone which is why I have to press that
button during authentication on this
particular device which means if there
is something else running on the phone
it'll never be able to physically press
the button which is kind of the same
premise with security keys that's why we
require a button press at the point in
time when we're going to do signature
even if there's something else maybe
malicious running it hopefully will not
be able to physically exercise my my
security keys button but we'll talk
about that
so let's now jump into a demo so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna ask folks to
switch over to the laptop right here and
I'll bring up the the phone here in a
second but let's start this is a user is
signed into Gmail right
it's a refresh and make sure everything
looks good cool I already use security
keys and this is kind of the state that
we want users to be in we we really want
users setting up their like phones
moulting security key to already have
something else that they can use if this
process fails that's why we're saying
beta not because of the technology
necessarily having an inherent problem
but you know you need bluetooth for this
to work and you're not always gonna be
on a machine that has bluetooth right
you have a desktop if you're signing on
unsupported platform let's say I don't
know like window it's written it's older
than Windows 10 younger older than
Windows 10 so lower you might have a
challenge so so the protocol right now
is supported on pretty much all Android
7 plus phones and Windows 10 Chrome OS
and and Mac OS but again Bluetooth is a
requirement so we kind of want you to
have a backup so this user isn't that
perfect state if I click on my account
details over here and I review my
security settings you will see under
2-step verification that this user has a
couple of security keys already set up
so this user happens to have a Titan USB
key one right here and a Titan Bluetooth
key this one right here so these things
already set up on the account today we
see this promo happening and the promo
says hey by the way you have a
compatible Android phone already on your
account the way we know this is this
user already signed in to their Android
device using this Google Account at some
previous time so we're all kind of able
to correlate this and say hey we think
you have a compatible phone for the
technology this promo might take a
little while to show up for your account
however if you just click the add
security key button you should
immediately be able to use this
technology that was already released
this morning so if you click add
security key which I'll do in this case
you'll see all your various options if
you don't have any eligible firms it'll
go straight into the hey added you USB
or Bluetooth a security key in this case
I happen to have a compatible pixel 3 on
my account if you have more than one
phone they'll all show up here and you
can pick what you want to use I've got
my pixel 3 at this point which is what
I'm gonna activate I'm gonna click it
it'll tell me a bunch of like things
like I need Bluetooth and location and
other things on on the phone for this
technology to work don't need pairing
that's kind of the critical part you
write with other abilities keys that we
spoke about earlier we needed pairing
right we need to pair this device with
our phone or with our laptop for it to
work we listen to our users and they
don't like pairing it's hard if you ever
try to pair a phone and laptop together
like it's not easy we wanted to get away
from that so we said what can we do to
make the protocol easier
so we basically came up with a little
extension to the web within protocol
that's standardized right now and this
extension allows for pairing less secure
communication between your laptop and
your phone
the protocol extension is being
standardized in the standards
organization Fido as we speak it has not
completely been ratified yet it takes a
while
we've decided this Chrome to do the
first implementation of that any other
browser of course is free to do the same
thing but we wanted to get it out there
so we can start testing what's this
particular protocol so we expect other
browsers to pick it up right now all
right some point too but right now
chrome is the browser where this
protocol is simple minutes anyway we'll
add in the end it'll say hey
everything's cool so I'll go back and I
see three security keys on my god I've
got my big google pixel 3 I've got my
USB key and I have my bluetooth key so
now let's see how this works during
signing so I will close this window I
will open a new incognito window and at
this point I'm going to try and display
my pixel 3 on this screen so let's move
that out of the way all right so this is
my phone what I have Europe and I'm
gonna try noxious Gmail so gmail.com
I am going to enter demo account
credentials and at this point in time I
should see the new UI appearing which
you know tells me I can use either USB
or Bluetooth of course but I'm gonna
pick to use my phone that's the default
if you have a phone on your account
you've seen a message pop up this is a
pixel 3 experience which says I have to
hold down the volume down button which
I'm gonna do I'm gonna click it and hold
it down until the blue checkmark appears
it's gonna be local bluetooth
connectivity between these two devices
and once that completes I will be
allowed to sign in to my account and at
this point it did all of those checks
that we spoke about earlier there was
challenges pass the phone signed it the
key material happened to be stored in
the tighten em chip crypt there happened
there and we also made sure on the way
back that I was actually looking at the
legitimate website here the real
mail.google.com and not some other
malicious website perhaps arms anyway so
that's kind of the demo so we'll go back
to this lighting at this point and we'll
see what happened there so how this fit
in same picture right I'm just gonna go
through it really quickly because we
really discussed this already and all
the point of this picture is just to
show it's exactly the same technology
and the same protocol that would be
using like with USB and physical ability
security keys in place here same thing
right we're sending data over it can be
sent by other USB NFC or ble and this
point it was sent via ble and phone
signed it send it all the way back and
the server validated that this was the
correct key the correct secret right
that signed this this cryptographic
challenge so pretty straightforward you
know I didn't have to go into this too
much of course it offers a stronger
defense against phishing that's kind of
the point we're trying to make and it's
very verifies users identity in the URL
the URL that you're visiting this is
kind of the takeaway slide right if
there's two things do you remember from
this presentation and this is what
security keys do it's about the protocol
it's not about the physical form factor
ever since we started down the path of
security keys the intent was always to
bring the thing in your pocket to kind
of you know be that technology that you
can use without having to make the user
carry around something else you know of
course security keys has its place you
still use that to to bootstrap an
account have that as your backup but you
now have one additional option
it's just technologically much easier to
make the
devices then implement everything
directly on the device itself inside the
phone so so kind of as you know the last
one of the last sections here I want to
just show the difference between the
non-security key push based
authentication protocol and the Porsche
based authentic sorry and the we ble
based authentication protocol right so
push based authentication protocol the
one that goes by the cloud normally that
you know even we offered this Google
right it's been the name that we call it
Google prompt so you can activate Google
prompt you could have you know said that
up as your qsv mechanism for ages we
actually change it over a couple of
months maybe a year ago so that you can
set that up as your default option so if
you activate you stay purification or
multi-factor authentication on a Google
account today Google prompt is the
option that you're gonna get it's great
but it's very like straightforward it
has the same user experience roughly as
what we've seen here but it sends the
messages via the clouds if you look at
what's going on on this diagram right
here
this is how users get tricked right user
guides and the user goes to a website at
this point I call it fishing comm but
it's you know a little bit more subtle
than that in real life I end up going to
a website that looks a lot like Google
but it's not really the real Google
website what in essence happening is I'm
visiting a website that's proxying all
of my information and all of the data
between the real Google and me so that's
what we're seeing in step 3 that's cool
that's the real Google servers however
I'm not interacting with it I'm
interacting with something that is
interacting with it so like there
proxying everything back to my to my
machine into my browser so what's
happening is user is interacting they're
typing in their username bad guys
getting it they're typing in their
password bad guys getting it they're
sending it on to the real Google real
Google happily sends the push message to
the real user who is trying to sign in
at this point but of course when I say
yes to that message I'm not signing me
and I'm signing the bad guy in and
there's no way for Google to know
whether they're interacting with the
legitimate user or with someone proxying
everything on the user's behalf that's
really the problem and one of the
reasons why these push messages contain
other metadata right it says things like
the law
occasion you're trying to sign in front
you might be like why is it telling me
we're under signing in from I know where
I'm signing in front well it's because
if someone is proxying that message
hopefully they're not in the same
location is you and you'll check that
message and see oh this guy's trying to
sign in from a different country or a
different state I'm clearly going to say
no to this message using IP geolocation
mostly so like nowadays it's very easy
for folks to set up VPN tunnels that
kind of you know pop out in roughly the
same neighborhood or areas that you're
in so that's that's another challenge
right there it's way to circumvent some
of these technologies other push
authentication technologies show you the
IP address of who you're seeing who
knows what their IP is when they're
trying to sign it like you're not gonna
go and check out what is my public
facing IP address every time that you do
one of these messages so even that kind
of stuff don't really really work it's
it sure we're putting more of the burden
back to the user where they can
potentially figure out whether they're
interacting with the legitimate site or
not but it's not that easy to tell we
wanted to solve that problem all right
to say well why don't we make it the
technology's problem and not the users
problem and that's really where we ended
up here much simpler picture right the
user is now looking at the phishing
website bad guy still up there to the
left but this time round because the
cunny communication to the mobile phone
is directly from the userís machine to
the phone and not as in the previous
picture from the google cloud to the
phone
we're able to tell the phone the URL
that the user is looking at and the
phone will either refuse to sign the
message or will sign it but we'll you
know send back the data to the cloud in
this case that what we're seeing is the
browser is sending back fishing calm in
that signature and Google is going like
no no no no that's not the website the
user should be looking at when they're
logging in so you know really really
straightforward if you think about the
technology again you know really
critically you know important but but
but very very simple and and that's how
you know we or at least the difference
between using traditional post based
mechanisms which again like there's
nothing wrong with it inherently it's
certainly better than not having any 2sv
at all
and certainly better than some other 2hv
options but if you want this enhanced
level of protection in the you know
early days you have to get one of these
now you have one more option and just
during your phone into it so so the
prompt on the phone looks very much the
same if you don't happen to have a
three device the prompt actually looks
pretty much exactly the same as the the
Google prompt technology if you look at
that screen there on the right and you
look at the one here it's very much
similar we don't show you any of the
other stuff anymore right we don't show
you the location or the IP address or
anything like that because at this point
is not important we know these things
are local that's the important part
so to kind of end off and wrap up here
it's convenient right users are prompted
to verify their signing on their phone
it's pretty straightforward there is a
one-time simple enrollment we've seen
that it's pretty straightforward you
don't need to install any apps on the
phone you don't even need to upgrade the
software of your Android phone it
happens automatically in the background
your phone should have it at this point
or Android seven plus devices should
have this and the way that we
technically get this to the furnace in
integration with something called Google
Play services which is like a back-end
component that lives in Android phones
that interact with with Google
properties so if you have access to
Gmail and other services on the device
typically this module is already present
and it's constantly updating in the
background and that's what we're using
to deliver this functionality to devices
going you know back a couple of years
right now it's available to more than
50% if you look at the you know
distribution of Android devices more
than 50% of user is running seven plus
so available to more than 50% of the
Android Market and it's free right you
never to pay anything for it you can
just enable it the only thing you need
is a compatible device and as I said
earlier there's you know one more thing
here which is if you happen to have a
pixel 3 device which has the Titan M
chip built into it we will actually be
using very much the same way that we
differentiate regular security keys
versus Titan security keys it's kind of
the same way that we differentiate you
know the built-in security key on
Android versus the built-in security key
on Android pixel 3 kind of the same
thing it's just a little bit more trust
in where those keys are actually stored
and in the way that you exercise it
again I won't you know I don't want to
go into too much detail on the
differences here and and say the one is
necessarily better than the other
remember the attack we're trying to
prevent against you is remote fishing
we're trying to prevent someone that's
in a different country or you know in a
different you know location than you
trying to sign in because that's the
threat that's scalable that's the thing
that we see on the web that's also the
stuff that we that uses freedom speak
about earlier right if we look
you know the amount of phishing websites
that's springing up every month it's
staggering that's the type of thing we
want to protect against and for that it
doesn't really matter where on your
phone the Kea store right it can be
stored done you know file system or in
the TE or in even in the Titan M trip it
doesn't really matter that much but we
do have this kind of additional level of
protection and the same has with the
physical Titan security key for folks
who care about that last slide here it's
available now in beta as we said it's
available on Android seven phones works
with Bluetooth enabled Chrome browser on
Chrome OS Mac OS X and Windows 10 and
you can use it both on your personal
gmail account as well as on any of our
enterprise accounts and if an
administrator set up an organization to
require a security key this is now a
valid way to kind of you know I guess
address that particular constraint where
you can set up your phone and it will
happily satisfy the constraint of using
a security key on that account
[Music]